halo 5 Guardians it's got arena bet you
didn't see that coming arena is the
latest iteration of 4v4 red on blue
action game types breakout strongholds
capture the flag and Slayer will see you
doing that thing you do with a few new
changes to shooting in Spartan movement
scratch that veteran halo players might
have to retrain their muscle memory
altogether first let's talk about guns
to begin with the Spartans now have a
smart link between their helmets and
their guns this allows you to zoom in
with every weapon and if this sounds
overpowered there's something to balance
it out shooting a player deactivates
their smart link and D scopes their site
so no more zoomed in battle rifle fights
as both players will be pecking each
other and D scoping every other shot
suppressive fires a thing now use it to
your advantage next up movement you have
an unlimited amount of sprint but while
sprinting your shields won't recharge I
mean it's not one of those kinetic
energy watches invented in the 21st
century it stops bullets and future
bullets and grenades did sometimes
elbows so make a decision walk briskly
to recharge your shield or double down
with a running Spartan charge sprint
forward and hit melee to pop an enemy
shield still moving forward increase
your pace with thrusters or go sideways
to juke grenades brake line of sight or
get out of the way to recharge shield
did you play call of duty advanced
warfare then you know what this does
next the clamber system will let you
hoist yourself over ledges and miss that
platforming jump by just a little bit
while still getting you where you want
to go probably back to your flag with
the enemy flag the final two movement
abilities in your arsenal of locomotion
are stabilizers which lets you hover for
a sec to scope out the battlefield
mostly I saw other people doing this and
use them as skeet shooting practice but
if you do get your hover on use the new
ground pound which after a bit of aiming
will get you to set enemies in deadly
fashion alright I didn't really get the
hang of ground pound but it looks real
cool the final thing you should know
about arena is that it feeds into the
new requisition system think pelo meet
scarbacks meets armaments ok really just
ain't titanfall's burn cards completing
matches will give you rec points to go
spend on setbacks which you can use back
in arena and war zone we call that a
hook
and that's about it but your circle on
the helmet and go bang till it dies for
more coverage of halo 5 guardians
including a more in-depth look at war
zone stay tuned to gamespot com
you